hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game you guys requested as soon as
it finished it's from the Tata steel
India rapid tournament that is currently
taking place in Kolkata India versus who
is currently basically the star of the
of the Chess World as he faced the
Magnus cross and in the finals of the
fide World Cup uh now for those who a
lot of you have been asking in the
comments throughout the years why is the
tournament called Tata or Tata steel
it's uh because the uh the still
Manufacturing Company Tata still from
India sponsors the event uh they if you
guys remember it wasn't called you have
two data Stills you have the big
classical tournament that takes takes
place in Vikings every year and you have
the rapid and Bliss that take place in
India and the until 2007 it was called
the chorus tournament also chorus is a
group that also was into steel and Tata
still acquired them and uh from 2007
onwards uh it wasn't the the chorus
tournament anymore it became the Tata
steel tournament so just that uh you
know clear that up a little bit but okay
getting back to this game it's a game
from round one Timo rajabo has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to D4
let's see what happened in this one it's
quite a wonderful game and also features
a great opening Knight to F6 uh we have
Pawn to C4 by Taylor uh E6 Knight to F3
and now Bishop to B4 check now when I
play and uh you okay so most of the time
your opponents will go for the names of
Indian or rather Knight to C3 an
invitation to the names of Indian you
play Bishop to B4 and you are very happy
but sometimes your opponents will play
Knight F3 sort of the anti-nimzo uh but
you can still play Bishop to B for check
even though the Knight is not on C3 this
is not the BOGO Indian defense and also
uh allows a great play uh with black so
Bishop to D2 Queen to E7 interestingly
this is the nimsovich variation of the
BOGO Indian we have G3 and Bishop
captures on D2 We have Queen capture so
the bishop uh the dark Square versus get
traded off the board unlike in the names
of where you will trade Metro for night
night the C6 and now Knight the C3 with
Pawn to D5 and the bishop to G2 and
pragos for the immediate the D captors
on C4 he gives the Tamer the full Center
but he will get counter play on The
Queen side we have castles uh King side
castles King said by Prague as well and
now Pawn to E4 uh Tamer grabs the full
Center and Rook to B8 interestingly okay
you can even go for A6 B5 and more often
than not white will not try to prevent
this usually when you play A6 or Rook to
B8 to prepare uh Pawn to B5 white will
just play Pawn to A4 and stop this but
here if you play Ponte A4 it's not as
great then the Knight that has all sorts
of Knight A5 the B3 moves also the
Knight can come to B4 and then go
immediately to D3 which white cannot
prevent as the bishop has already been
finchetto the bishop does not control D3
so you will not see A4 uh when you play
this and you don't have to worry about
it rook fd1 and now Rook to d8 and it is
now already as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so rotate the D1
just going for for the full Center the
Rooks are already on D and E files and
pawn to B5 we have Pawn to A3 and pawn
to A5 now preparing the strike with B4
and Knight to D5 by temer it's not a
peace sacrifice because uh well Prague
even captures it and allows this now the
queen is attacked and the Knight we have
Queen to D6 and now D captures and C6
but the real problem uh occurs if you if
you uh cap from C6 as well you have to
allow this Pawn to stay alive if you
capture it then comes 95 with the double
attack on the queen and wherever you
move your queen Knight comes to C6 and
wins one of the Rooks uh so of course
Prague does not touch the pawn he goes
for Pawn to B4 uh Knight to E5 and now
Bishop to E6 just continuing development
at any time proc can just play C3 and
create a pass Pawn not right now but you
know in the future a cap for some B4 we
have eight not a captors or Rook
captures but Prague goes for Queen
captures he offers a queen trade Queen
captures and a captors and now uh
certainly if uh C3 is played a prog will
create a past pawn pawn to D5 of course
the Tamer will not just wait around for
that so he temporarily sacrifices a pawn
to capture on C4 and it doesn't matter
what you capture with if you capture
with the bishop first timer will trade
and then capture the pawn or if you
capture with the Knight like Prague did
then you can capture and see for right
away so King to a f8 brock starts
bringing the king into the game and now
Ponta H3 we have rooked the A8 trying to
get that Rook all the way down the
border and of course a rook to A1
countering that we have Pawn to B3 by
frog and now Knights the e 5. we have
Rook captures on A1 now probably you're
wondering if Rook to A2 is a mover if we
can play that maybe double up on the a
file should be good for black but this
is uh no more than a draw offer it would
seem because after Knight the D7 check
there are all sorts of tactics that work
in tamer's favor for example Bishop
capture spawn captures Rook captures
okay you're up a pawn but now let's say
rotate the D1 you go after the Knight
here and if you play Knight B6 you offer
a trade you can simply capture captures
captures and play Bishop to C6 and now
the Knight can't really move because of
checkmate
uh the Knight is hanging so you have to
do something about that you have to play
Knight F6 to prevent Checkmate and now
you're gonna play rookie two you're
gonna defend the pawn and you're gonna
go after that B3 Pawn capture back the
pawn so you're either down opponent for
the rest of the game or you know you
will you will probably have to give it
up but it's not really an attempt to win
especially with um a white having a
bishop against Knight with play being on
both sides of the board so it's pretty
much a drawish so instead Prague goes
for the much stronger Rook captures on
A1 Rook captures and now King the E7 he
knows that the real weakness of his
position is the C7 pawn and he wants to
get an early start with his King to
start defending that we have Rook to A7
and King to D6 now defense and attacks
on E5 Knight to C4 check and now King
the C5
um okay the the Knight for the moment is
defending C7 but you always have to
worry about Bishop captures and real
captures on C7 so he moves the king with
Tempo uh the Knight is hanging Knights
to D2 and now Knight to F6 again which
tempo as the Knight is again hanging
lights the E4 width check we have
captors captures and now we have Rook to
D1 with check you have to now be very
careful your Pawn here is hanging in
your Pawn here is hanging although you
never really want to capture this one
the the bishop can easily be trapped
or maybe you can't trap the bishop in
order to capture it but maybe you can
just keep it out of the game which is
also pretty bad for white so came to G2
and now King to D6 the king retreats to
defend the C7 Pawn with rooked A8 and
now King to E5 with Tempo the bishop is
hanging King to F3 defending and now
Rook to E1 hoping to win the bishop so
Rook to A5 with check kicks away the
king Kink the D6 and now Pawn to G4 we
have Pawn to H6 uh and Rook the B5 again
putting pressure on the B3 Pawn uh with
Bishop to C4 attacking The Rook pushing
it away and The Rook the B for now we
have King to C5 defense and attacks Rook
to B7 and King back to D6 so you have a
uh this weird situation on the queen
side where uh both players have a light
Square Bishop they both have to defend
their pawns on light squares on the
queen side and both of them want to
attack the other guy's Pawn that is on a
dark Square so it's a really really a
mind game uh We've rooked the B4 and now
Bishop to E6 here if you go King to C5
then for example Rook the B7 and King to
D6 you can just go for a repetition here
but of course I don't think either of
them wanted that so Bishop back to E6
and now Rook to D4 with check with King
to E5 Rook back to B4 and now Pawn to G5
grabbing more space here now the king
cannot touch the F4 and H4 squares Rook
the B5 check with King to D4 and now
Rook back to B4 with check Bishop to C4
and Rook to A4 with King to C5 and now
Rook back to A7 going after the pawn
here so Rook backing back to D6 and The
Rook to A4 goes after the bishop Bishop
to e to check now Prague has to try
something else in order to avoid
repetition King G3 and Bishop back to B5
attacking the rook and Hearn you uh you
have to play Rook day 5 and settle for a
repetition Bishop C4 and then King to F3
and we can repeat this once more but uh
Tamer went active he played Rook to D4
with check King to C5 and now Rook to D5
with check he played King to B6 uh King
to B4 can also be played or King to C4
King to B6 was played and now Rook to D4
with Rook to G1 with check King to F3
and now Rook to H1 going after the pawn
here uh King G3 defending and now Rook
the C1 now ready to capture on C6 so
King to F3 and now that Bishop to C4 of
course if you capture on uh on C6 then
just Bishop capture skin captures and
while you won a pawn there's really
nothing to defend the B3 Pawn so it's
not really winning a pawn so Bishop to
C4 was played uh and now King the E3 we
have King the C5 and now Rook to DC 7
again going for the pawn here Rook to E1
check with King to F3 and now King to B6
again defending the C7 Pawn which is
like really a theme of the game Rook the
D4 attacks the bishop Bishop to E6 and
now Rook the B4 check with King to C5
and The Rook to B7 King to D6 once again
so it's really just going back and forth
to Rook to B4 uh Rook to H1 uh proxating
a little trap here and uh Rook the D4
with check with King the E5 and now Rook
to D2 but the problem is uh now that
even though uh proc can win a pawn maybe
there's a better move here in fact the
position is completely winning for
Prague and uh well it's not easily uh
supportable how to do that so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Prague while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
trapped and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a rook the
E1 this is what proc played and he was
in this position on move 62 that Timo
rajabo resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here now of
course the bishop can move but where are
you moving the bishop that's the that's
the question doesn't really matter where
you move it if you play something like
Bishop to F5 you get Bishop to D5 check
and now the King has only the G3 square
look at The Rook covers this point can
cover that Bishop covers G2 so only G3
is available to the white king then
comes Rook G1 check and after King H2
rooked the G2 check forces the king into
a windmill King H1 and now Rook captures
an F2 check will win the Rook on D2 so
the D2 Square was really not the the
best of squares for the Rook uh so you
know uh tough luck for for teamwork but
yeah really uh really shows how even
when your opponent doesn't allow you to
play the names of Indian defense uh you
see how you can get a lot of action with
with the BOGO Indian okay you have to
trade Bishop for Bishop most of the
times but uh still all the all the
motives and all the ideas that you can
maybe use in in the Indonesia Indian are
available to you here and you always get
a very nice game uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other favorites from the Tata
still in the rapid do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over them I
would like to thank uh Jaron Asher
rohantana David Kimura obvious mimic.com
and Gerard Princeton for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day